alan dershowitz is a symbol of Batarian
famously so he's a retired Harvard Law
School professor he's the author of the
book the case against impeaching Trump
and he joins us tonight professor it
does it bother you that a law
enforcement agency and it doesn't need
to be the FBI under Jim Comey it could
be any American law enforcement agency
at any time would leak damaging in some
cases classified information about
targets of their investigations why why
would you want to live in a country
where that happens I've been bothered by
this since J Edgar Hoover J Edgar Hoover
who notoriously lived by leaks he would
threaten political enemies that he would
leak information about their sex lives
and about their private life and it was
wrong it was wrong then it's wrong real
and when an FBI agent or a prosecutor
leaks Grand Jury material it's criminal
what we need now is an objective
investigation by the inspector general
by the Office of Professional
Responsibility into these leaks and into
what was meant by the email that said
that we have a leak strategy it's hard
to believe that that meant that we have
a strategy to stop leaks it seems much
more plausible that he was talking about
a strategy designed to leak things
selectively to the media in order to
achieve the goal he had set out for
himself namely to have an insurance
policy against electing a man who he
thought was dangerous to the country
look he has a right to his opinion he
had a right to vote any way he wanted he
doesn't have a right to try to influence
the outcome of an election through leaks
now I'm taken by the point that he may
not have leaked before the election we
have to look into that we have to find
out about that and that's what the
Inspector General is about now your
previous guest mentioned the
investigation by Congress but as far as
I know at least I didn't know about this
email during that investigation he
wasn't asked about it if that email
exists and is authentic it should have
been in the hands of the people who are
asking him the questions he may have to
be called back now to answer questions
about what he meant under oath what he
meant by saying we have a leak strategy
I doubt that he will say under oath
oh it was intended to make sure there
were no leaks that just doesn't pass the
giggle test it so very quickly why are
more people not outraged by this does
anyone want to lead us everybody was
taking such an agency I know but this
isn't a side this is the side know of
every American who's subject to the FBI
or any law enforcement agency I mean
this should be scary some Democrats as
well as rangerous it is so dangerous to
every American
today it's Trump there after tomorrow it
could be Bernie Sanders or Hillary
Clinton and the day after tomorrow it
could be you and me that's why every
civil libertarian Democrat and
Republican has to be concerned about
government by leaked look we want full
disclosure we want a lot of information
that's now classified to be disclosed
but there are proper ways of disclosing
this and you know who's at fault to this
more than anyone else Comey because he
leaked information and laundered it
through a professor at Columbia Law
School
shame on that professor and shame on
call me if Comey didn't have the courage
to stand up in front of a TV camera and
say look I feel so strongly about this
that I'm going to give you this
information but no he snuck the
information to a law professor who
collaborated with him and getting the
information and causing the appointment
of a special counsel without having the
courage of his conviction to stand up
that's what a civil libertarian would do
that's what he's a patriotic American
would do of course but now he's the hero
of the resistance he's Charles DeGaulle
a professor thank you very much